[موسيقى
] تعلم أن سنغافورة تُعرف باسم مدينة الحدائق ،
لذلك
كان هناك الكثير من المناظر الطبيعية التي
تحدث لديك بقع عشبية بين
المباني واليوم
هناك دفعة أوسع
من الحكومة
لتحقيق مستوى من الأمن الغذائي داخل
قطاع الزراعة المحلي لدينا
[موسيقى  ]
قررنا بدء
مزرعة كبيرة نسبيًا
في وسط سنغافورة
[موسيقى]
لذلك صممنا المزرعة
من بعض النواحي كنظام إنتاج حلقة مغلقة
لأنه
في سنغافورة بينما نستورد 90 من طعامنا ،
نرمي 700000  طن سنويًا
[موسيقى]
لذلك على مدار السنوات التسع الماضية ، قمنا
بتصميم وصيانة ما يقرب
من 260 حديقة ،
ويمكن أن يكون هذا من منازل
الناس وحتى مشاريع البناء التجارية الأكبر ،
أعتقد أنه كان هناك
الكثير من
الحديث
حول التأثير الذي يمكن أن تحدثه الزراعة الحضرية
على مستقبل المدن
حيث ينتقل المزيد والمزيد من الناس
إلى المدينة من المناطق الريفية ،
لذا فإن الزراعة الحضرية
بطريقة ما لديها
القدرة على  قلل
بعض انبعاثات الكربون هذه
من النمو
محليًا وبالطبع توفير
المنتجات الطازجة
مباشرة إلى المجتمع الذي يستهلكها ،
لذا فهي
مفيدة أيضًا
من بعض النواحي من حيث العناصر الغذائية
وكذلك عندما يتم زراعتها
محليًا وداخل البيئة الحضرية
التي نعمل معها عن كثب  إلى 50 إلى 60
نوعًا مختلفًا من
الأعشاب
والخضروات والفواكه
، ثم نقوم أيضًا بزراعة
المزيد من الخضروات العصرية مثل اللفت
وما نقوم به أيضًا
بشكل فريد تمامًا هو إنتاج
سلسلة كاملة من الزهور المحلية الصالحة للأكل
والتي يتم
زراعتها وحصدها أيضًا  للمطاعم المحلية
[موسيقى]
أنت